the opioid crisis sweeping the country
is putting a growing financial and
emotional strain on many communities
more than 4,000 people died from
unintentional drug overdoses last year
in Ohio alone many corners in the state
say the death toll will be higher this
year Tony de copal visited one hard-hit
town in Butler County where the sheriff
is refusing to allow deputies to carry
the opioid antidotes over safety
concerns Tony good morning good morning
according to one estimate opioids could
kill nearly a half million people over
the next decade that's like losing the
entire population of Atlanta we went to
Middletown Ohio where the situation is
rapidly deteriorating the city has
already seen more overdose calls this
year than in all of 2016 and some there
are proposing extreme solutions we were
along for the ride as first responders
in Middletown Ohio made their way to a
fifth overdose call in just over an hour
last thing the chief said when we walked
out the door was there's a bad batch
that's correct
it seems that you know the dealer may
have made his rounds and various people
are starting to fall out now on this
call we saw a woman turning blue on the
ground outside her friend's house
medics work quickly and were able to
save her at least for now what's it like
for you to see her like this it's
breaking my heart
they just tell me just over those two
nights ago I mean how many times she
calls like this have risen dramatically
in recent months last year Middletown
EMS made 532 runs for opioid overdoses
this year they've already had more than
600 runs through June and they're using
more naloxone to counter the effects of
stronger synthetic drugs city leaders
say they've surpassed the 11 thousand
dollars they spent on the treatments
last year and are on pace to spend more
than $100,000 this year my issue is that
we're gonna run out of money that's why
city councilman Dan Picard is proposing
a three strikes plan those who overdosed
once or twice would have to perform
community service and pay off the cost
of the emergency response if they don't
there might not be a response the third
time my message statics is yeah stay
away from Middletown because we might
not show up to treat you harsh it's
reality your way to dictate who's
saleable and who's not saleable
Middletown EMS saved Shelley Thompson's
life when she overdosed on opioids in
2015 yeah I was two minutes away from
not being able to be here she tells us
she's been clean for a year and a half
and insists any threat to withhold EMS
service won't deter addicts the addict
is not scared you know they're hopeless
they're helpless we need to help these
people not more death we need to be more
involved in forcing some type of
treatment police chief rodney mueller
spa has his own proposal he'd like to
arrest overdose patients and file
criminal charges which the government
would drop if the patient agrees to get
help it's unclear how well this would
work a study last year found little
evidence that compulsory drug treatment
is effective what gives you confidence
that force treatment would be effective
you know I can't tell you it gives me a
lot of confidence but it's better than
what we're doing now because we're doing
nothing now
later that afternoon Middletown first
responders raced to another call this
I'm saving a man who overdosed in a
store parking lot they say it goes on
like this all day I'm a city councilor
my job as the city councilor is to make
sure this city can continue to function
and provide services to its citizens and
at the rate we're going we've got to do
something are the wheels turning for
change oh I think the wheels are
definitely turning it's it's at a point
where it has to change so people are
forced to make change
Middletown eMS responded to a total of
eight overdose calls on the single day
we were there at this point the idea to
withhold a response is only that an idea
not a formal proposal and it's unclear
whether it would ever withstand a legal
challenge since first raising the idea
the City Councilman admits the feedback
has mostly been negative but he points
out he's at least sparked a debate about
what to do and I should I should add
that the the negative reaction has been
mostly from outside Middletown within
the town they're facing a choice between
bankruptcy and a medical response one
would think there's got to be some
solution between what's happening now
and not doing anything at all they want
federal aid which they haven't seen so
far because it costs how much to respond
to one case of an overdose about a
thousand dollars and in a small town
with a 25 million dollar budget they're
looking at spending two million dollars
on heroin and opioid overdoses alone
thanks